new concerns tonight about China's
influence inside the United States and
the concerns are coming from within Tick
Tock The Wall Street Journal is
reporting a string of high-level execs
have transferred from parent company
bite dance to Tick-Tock and from Beijing
to the United States company meetings
are even conducted in Chinese now it's
making U.S staff very worried about how
much control China has over Tick Tock
despite their past protestations of the
contrary joining me now Congressman Mike
Gallagher chair of the select committee
on the CCP Congressman our friend Mike
Pompeo warned about this in 2019 you've
warned about it but the Biden
Administration hands off oh they're
going to have a can we call it a Chinese
wall between China and Tick-Tock doesn't
seem like that's there well if you
remember the CEO of tick tock came to
Congress and testified and specifically
cast out on the level of control that
bite dance had over Tick Tock which was
absurd at the time for anyone following
this but now it proven to be a lie Tick
Tock is controlled by bite dance and
bite dance is of course controlled by
the Chinese Communist party so therefore
we cannot allow the CCP to control the
dominant media platform in America yet
Congress has been silent on this issue
and paralyzed for months now because of
a massive lobbying campaign
multi-million dollar allotment campaign
on behalf of tick tock they're
weaponizing the DC swamp against us but
we have to act before it's too late um
well a bombshell report speaking of
China just came out from Politico the
CCP nabbed 60
000 emails from the state department we
knew there was a hack but we didn't know
how pervasive it was among the most
sensitive information stolen where
victims travel itineraries in diplomatic
deliberations congressmen we can't even
secure our email in our government
what's our federal budget now that for
the state department what's their I.T
budget yeah it's right it's massive but
here's what makes it even worse it's we
remember we had previous report that the
Commerce secretary's emails were hacked
and what does she do after that report
she went to Beijing to engage with the
Chinese Communist party so despite the
fact that the CCP has not relaxed its
Relentless economic and cyber Warfare
campaign against us the Biden
Administration is trying to revive
economic and diplomatic engagement with
China as the foundation of our foreign
policy it's naive it's dangerous because
we slow key defensive action that we
need to take to defend ourselves and so
China is not slowing down but we're
slowing down because of some mistaken
assumptions we have about the nature
we're going to have you back to talk
about what's happening with Ford and the
Auto industry and China's influence on
that as well Congressman thank you so
much thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else